die dunkle materie wo hält sie sich
versteckt möglicherweise suchen wir ganz
falsch im weiten und fern weltall
denn möglicherweise kommen wir hier
mitten unter uns auf der erde viel
einfacher ihr auf die schliche russische
fachleute sind davon überzeugt und
betreiben neutrino forschung an einem
wirklich außergewöhnlichen ort mit hilfe
eines riesigen unterwasser teleskops
klicks um science and future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's haben sich mit komplexen gibt
es ja inzwischen auch als podcast wäre
es also bisher verpasst hat und klicks
um auf die ohren möchte mit der einen
oder anderen side story und noch mehr
infos dem würde ich mal sagen abonnieren
und anhören klickt auf die links spotify
und apple podcast in der wir
beschreibung im angebunden kommentar und
hier unter mir dunkle materie ist
unsichtbar sie sendet weder licht aus
noch reflektiert sie dieses noch nie hat
sie irgend jemand gesehen und ihr
direkter nachweis steht bis heute aus
dabei sucht die fachwelt sehr intensiv
dennoch gehört das rätsel rund um die
dunkle materie wohl weiterhin zu den
wichtigsten ungeklärten fragen der
physik und kosmologie und so läuft schon
seit vielen jahren ein unerbittlicher
und äußerst spannender wettstreit
zwischen forschungsteams weltweit ab sie
endlich aufzuspüren und dingfest zu
machen russische wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler haben sich dafür
einen eher außergewöhnlichen ort
ausgesucht einen riesigen süßwassersee
so haben die fachleute in diesen tagen
eines der größten unterwasser
weltraumteleskope der welt gestartet der
name gigatonnen volume detector oder
kurz bei kiwi die die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hoffen darauf aus den unberührten
gewässern des baikalsees tief ins
universum blicken zu können hier also
startet jetzt die jagd nach dem
unsichtbaren was steckt wirklich hinter
diesem experiment und wie groß sind die
chancen dass so endlich das rätsel der
dunkle materie gelüftet werden kann
versteht der baikalsee ist in sibirien
mit rund 1600 metern nicht nur der
tiefste sondern mit einem alter von 25
millionen jahren auch der älteste sie
zudem handelt es sich auch noch um den
wasserreichsten süßwassersee der erde
nicht verwunderlich dass sich viele
mythen um diesen außergewöhnlichen ort
der erde ranken immer wieder wird von
geheimnisvollen ufo-sichtungen über dem
baikalsee berichtet eine weitere theorie
geht sogar davon aus dass ihr angeblich
eine alien station unter wasser tief im
baikal see errichtet wurde
oft ist auch von einem seemonster und
angeblichen gold schätzen die rede doch
den russischen fachleuten vom institut
für kernforschung ist es ernst sie haben
mitte märz 2021 ein gigantisches
unterwasser neutrino teleskop in baikal
see versenkt und zwar bis zu einer tiefe
von 750 und 1300 metern vier kilometer
vom seeufer entfernt das berichtet die
nachrichtenagentur ap
die russischen forschenden sind auf der
suche nach neutrinos und der baikalsee
bietet demnach ausgezeichnete
bedingungen um neutrinos zu messen dazu
später mehr
fachleute gehen davon aus dass dunkle
materie höchstwahrscheinlich aus
neuartigen uns noch unbekannten teilchen
besteht diese stabilen teilchen könnten
sich möglicherweise im frühen universum
gebildet haben und sich dann kurz nach
dem urknall von normaler materie
entkoppelt haben lange zeit galten die
neutrinos als idealer kandidat für die
dunkle materie
doch mittlerweile geht man in aktuellen
bilanzen des universums davon aus dass
diese möglicherweise nur einen kleinen
teil der dunklen materie ausmachen
die erklärung dafür die neutrinos im
frühen universum waren extrem
energiereich und haben sich wohl nahezu
mit lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegt
fachleute halten sie aufgrund dessen für
heiße dunkle materie age bmj dark matter
um diese hätte strukturen wie unsere
galaxie durch ihre ungehinderte bewegung
verhindert
als aussichtsreichste kandidatin für die
mysteriöse dunkle materie gilt geld
mittlerweile teilchen die der neutrinos
ähnlich sind das weekly interacting
massive particles ein schwach
wechselwirken des massereiches teilchen
die fachwelt nutzt neben den direkt
methoden die sogenannten indirekten
methoden um dunkle materie aufzuspüren
hier geht es vor allem um
das aufspüren von sekundär teilchen die
aus der vernichtung von teilchen dunkler
materie in himmels regionen von hoher
dichte entsteht beispielsweise der sonne
oder dem zentrum unserer galaxie in der
fachsprache ist von der sogenannten
annihilation die rede
der begriff stammt aus dem lateinischen
und bedeutet soviel wie zunichte machen
es geht hier also um den prozess der
vernichtung ein elementarteilchen und
sein anti-teilchen verwandeln sich in
andere teilchen die produkte solche
animationen von dunkler materie wie
beispielsweise antimaterie gammastrahlen
oder eben neutrinos können somit von
fachleuten auf verschiedene arten und
weisen nachgewiesen werden unter anderem
mit teilchendetektoren für kosmische
strahlen im weltraum aber auch im eis
der antarktis ist das möglich ihr haben
wir schon öfter über das neutrino rtos
am südpol das ice cubes aus ton neutrino
observatorien berichtet und zwar in
mehreren kilometern tiefe
das alarmsystem des ice cubes hat das
ziel astronomie teams weltweit sofort
über die richtung und energie der
registrierten neutrinos zu informieren
so schnell wie möglich sollen dann alle
verfügbaren messgeräte und teleskope auf
den identifizierten himmels bereich
gerichtet werden doch auch neutrino
teleskop in großer wassertiefe sollen
neutrinos auf die schliche kommen der
grund warum die messgeräte so tief
versenkt werden liegt auf der hand denn
in kilometern tiefe im wasser oder eis
sind es weniger anderer
elementarteilchen die die messung stören
würden dennoch sind auch diese messungen
im untergrund alles andere als einfach
der neutrinos werden oft auch als die
geister der teilchen welt beschrieben
sie haben sehr wenig masse und
wechselwirken vor allem sehr selten mit
materie neutrinos durchdringend materie
ohne probleme und genau das macht sie so
schwer aus spürbaren es handelt sich
also um die jagd nach dem unsichtbaren
das unterwasser teleskop das jetzt im
baikal see versenkt wurde hat eine
bauzeit von rund fünf jahren hinter sich
und die verantwortlichen fachleute sind
sich sicher dass sie auf der richtigen
spur sind statt also den himmel ab zu
scannen setzen sie auf das medium wasser
denn ihrer ansicht nach sind die
bewegung von neutrinos hier viel besser
nachzuweisen als in der
dazu maier schäuble noch vom joint
institute for nuclear research in einem
interview mit der nachrichtenagentur ap
der biker sei der einzige see an dem man
aufgrund seiner tiefe ein neutrino
teleskop einsetzen kann
das süßwasser ist wichtig unter anderem
wegen der klarheit des wassers und auch
die tatsache dass ist dreieinhalb monate
lang eine eisdecke gibt ist ebenfalls
sehr wichtig denn zwischen februar und
anfang april bietet die eisdecke eine
stabile arbeitsplattform für die
forschenden um das teleskop im see zu
versenken war einige arbeit nötig das
teleskop besteht aus vielen optischen
modulen quasi die augen
diese werden an langen stahlseilen in
einer tiefe von bis zu 1200 40 metern im
wasser versenkt in der finsternis der
tiefe geht es letztlich darum die
sogenannten yankov strahlung zu
beobachten damit gemeint ist eine
bläuliche leuchterscheinung in stoffen
die beim durchgang radioaktiver
strahlung entstehen also beim durchgang
von neutrinos in diesem fall im engeren
sinne ist eine elektromagnetische
strahlung gemeint die entsteht wenn sich
geladene teilchen in einem medium
bewegen wichtig hierbei die
geschwindigkeit des teilchens ist größer
als die lichtgeschwindigkeit in diesem
medium zurück zum unterwasser teleskopen
baikalsee hier will man also die
strahlung aus spüren die vereinfacht
gesagt entsteht wenn die rasen neutrinos
mit wasser atom zusammenstoßen denn so
können die fachleute dann rückschlüsse
auf die unsichtbaren neutrinos schließen
diese fernen himmelsboten landen auf der
anderen seite der erde vor der küste
chiles und tauchen in die tiefe kein
problem für sie durch die erde hindurch
zu gelangen als millionen fliegen sie
schneller als das licht in diesem medium
durch das wasser und erzeugen so eine
art optischen überschallknall diese
lichtsensoren in den unterirdischen
glaskugeln des unterwasser teleskops
können die stärke und ankunftszeit des
lichtblicks registrieren durch die
zeitdaten kann dann die
richtungsbestimmung erfolgen so kann
dann letztendlich also die lage des
lichtkegels berechnet werden so erhält
man die bahn des millionen und somit
auch die richtung des neutrinos diese
methode der neutrino detektion hatte der
russische physiker alexander wetsch
markov bereits im jahr 1960
vorgeschlagen so wurde dann später auch
ein unterwasser neutrino teleskop im
baikalsee damals in der sowjetunion
realisiert
auch das forschungszentrum de sie war
mit beteiligt am baikal teleskop hatte
sich dann später aber am ice cube
projekt beteiligt doch die große
herausforderung damals wie heute nur
eine äußerst geringe zahl an audrey nuss
wird auf die atome des wassers treffen
heißt also um hier erfolge zu erzielen
muss ein riesiges wasservolumen
beobachtet werden und das wahrscheinlich
über jahre hinweg
erst dann können statistisch relevante
muster entdeckt werden die russischen
fachleute wollen das unterwasser
teleskop bei karl gigatonnen wollte
direktor deswegen weiter ausbauen so
dass eine wassermenge achtung von 440
kubikkilometern beobachtet werden kann
ja und diese 440 kilometer das ist
wirklich absolut riesig nach den angaben
der russischen fachleute zählt es somit
neben dem ice cube am südpol und antares
im mittelmeer zu den drei größten
neutrino und detektoren der welt die
große hoffnung aller projekte endlich
die gigantischen prozesse im universum
verstehen durch die teilchen auf höchste
energie beschleunigt werden bisher
ungelöste prozesse der astrophysik
könnten so endlich verstanden werden und
die größte hoffnung endlich der
mysteriösen dunklen materie auf die
schliche zu kommen
wir bleiben natürlich dran am thema und
mehr dazu gibt es hier
auf die ohren im podcast also anklicken
anhören und abonnieren
ansonsten bis dann dran